[Musique]
alors avec nous au panel ce soir Michel
David Chantal Hébert et allais
castonguet bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
on revient tout de suite sur l'énoncé
économique qui a été présenté par la
ministre des Finances cristal Freeland
première fois qu'on parle de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire pour le
gouvernement Trudeau on parle dans un
horizon de 5 ans c'est un nouveau
message délibéraux que pensez-vous de
cette énoncé économique Michel va
commencer oui clairement c'est la
première fois depuis que Monsieur
Trudeau est arrivé au pouvoir en 2015
qu'on commence à parler d'un retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire comme d'un
objectif important pour le gouvernement
alors oui il y a certainement un
changement de temps il est certain que
la situation
impose la zone certaines retenu là il y
a un risque sérieux de récession même si
Madame Freeland le point évoqué
clairement et au moment où un
ralentissement comme ça ce profil il est
clair qu'il faut commencer à penser à
comment dire un repas un comportement
budgétaire plus resp
mais politiquement aussi il est certain
que un moment donné on peut pas rester
totalement indifférent au discours des
conservateurs qui vont marteler ça d'une
façon récurrente
au cours des prochains mois alors là qui
aurait eu encore plus facilement si
Monsieur c'est Madame Freeland n'avait
pas évoqué ça alors il y avait à la fois
du réalisme et du de l'intelligence
politique
politiques parce que ce qu'on comprend
d'abord ça va devenir une vertu dans la
prochaine campagne électorale fédérale
de présenter des budgets équilibrés
alors qu'on a fait campagne en 2015 en
premier temps de faire des déficits pour
investir au bon endroit mais en gros les
libéraux se mettent en piste pour
pouvoir dire au cours de la prochaine
campagne électorale qu'elles viennent
demain matin ou en 2025 qui est le bon
équilibrer le budget en 2027 2028 donc
ça va faire partie de l'arsenal et c'est
évident que c'est en partie une réaction
à l'arrivée de Pierre poiylievre en
scène et aussi au sondage qui montre il
y en avait un juste cette semaine
d'Abacus qui dit ce sur des grands
sujets où on demandait quelle partie est
le mieux placé pour
gérer la santé l'environnement gérer
l'économie sujet numéro un les
conservateurs l'emportaient avec une
bonne longueur d'avance sur des libéraux
de Justin Trudeau ont énormément dépensé
ces dernières années on veut changer
peut-être l'image de marque Alec avec
cette énoncé
ouais je suis d'accord avec mes
collègues je pense qu'il y a un
repositionnement là mais il y a aussi
une réalité économique c'est à dire que
l'économie canadienne a très bien
performé pendant les premiers mois de
l'année en plus l'inflation est très
élevée c'est bon pour les coffres des
gouvernements l'inflation on applique
l'inflation après la hausse des prix et
donc il aurait fallu pour qu'on ne
retrouve pas l'équilibre budgétaire en
cinq ans prévu par Madame fullet
aujourd'hui recommencer à dépenser
ajouter des programmes parce que
inévitablement on est obligé d'atteindre
l'équilibre budgétaire à 5 ans et c'est
plus dans l'air du temps les collègues
l'ont dit on est actuellement dans une
préparation électorale pour faire
attention plus on injecte d'argent plus
à stimule l'inflation on essaie de
baisser ça alors on était l'arrivée des
conservateurs coïncide aussi avec le
fait que les libéraux sont peut-être
rendu au bout de tous les programmes
qu'ils ont mis en place et à un moment
donné il faut être capable de ramener un
petit peu de rigueur budgétaire on va
écouter si vous voulez
au bout un moment où il se prépare
rencontrer les provinces pour parler de
financement en santé c'est quand même
heureux comme coïncidant les fameux
transferts en santé on va y revenir dans
quelques instants mais parlons de la
réaction donc de Monsieur falievre chez
les conservateurs on écoute
cette stratégie m'inflationniste
augmente les taxes sur le chauffage
l'essence et les épiceries tant que les
consommateurs seront debouts pour les
Canadiens pour leur chèque de paix pour
leur maison pour leurs économies et nous
allons voter contre cette stratégie
inflationniste bon alors les
conservateurs vont voter contre John
mexing lui d'une va voter en faveur
il a déjà mentionné alors qu'il y a
émotionné de son côté qu'il trouvait
juste être dos complètement déconnecté
des besoins des gens au niveau au niveau
financier pour faire face à l'inflation
Michel il est encore dit aujourd'hui
sauf qu'il le dit comme il avait dit
hier d'ailleurs que malgré
l'incompétence l'inconscience du
gouvernement Trudeau heureusement nous
sommes là pour le forcer à faire le
minimum pour les Canadiens et
ça il l'a pas dit mais on a compris ça
aussi et nous n'avons pas le goût
d'aller en élection alors
de la mise à jour
essentiellement c'était le scénario
était écrit d'avance la même façon
monsieur Poirier d'ailleurs monsieur
Poirier va pas parler du tout de ce que
contient des quelques mesures nouvelles
que contient la mise à jour il a
continué à faire le procès de la
politique inflationniste de la justice
inflation comme il dit alors ça aussi
c'était écrit dans le ciel disons que là
il y avait pas il y avait pas un gros
saspens parce que le minimum à faire
pour la population est-ce qu'on le
retrouve dans dans ce budget là Chantal
à votre avis
il y a déjà des mesures qui ont été mis
en place au début de l'année quand le
Parlement est revenu alors donc
le gouvernement libéral et n'importe
quel gouvernement à la même place
également un problème on peut pas
remettre de l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables et en même temps dire on
essaie de combattre l'inflation parce
que c'est comme de dire la Banque du
Canada fait une chose et nous on tente
de faire le contraire ce qui est pas
particulièrement étonnant dans le cas de
Monsieur poillie moi aussi j'ai remarqué
qu'il était complètement hors sujet mais
j'attends son discours parce que demain
il fait un gros discours économique
devant le empire club à Toronto j'ai
comme l'impression qu'il se gardait ses
munitions pour demain on va on va
essayer ça attentivement et puis vous
l'avez mentionné il y a donc ce risque
de récession on le voit aussi dans le
budget on parle dans le scénario
pessimiste d'un possible récession dès
le premier trimestre de 2023
la plupart des provinces c'est le cas du
terrain aussi s'attendre à ce qu'on a
une période de récession est-ce que sera
courte est-ce qu'elle sera longue est-ce
que ça aura profonde pour l'instant les
prévisions sont malgré le pessimisme
ambiant plus optimiste que ce qu'on
pourrait penser ça pourrait être assez
court peu profond et donc le temps de
rééquilibrer l'économie mais vous savez
on en a jamais vraiment idée de ces
récessions là quand ça commence comment
elles vont se terminer donc on se croise
les doigts autant Ottawa à Québec en
espérant que ça dure pas trop longtemps
que ça calme la demande pour être
capable d'éventuellement de faire
ralentir l'inflation mais il y a une
partie d'imprévisibilité là-dedans il y
en a une incertitude de plus en plus
grande pour les gouvernements et ça ils
devront en tenir compte et ça fait
partie de la réalité économique donc on
se garde des on se garde des munitions
on a autant Ottawa qu'à Québec là on
sera pas très dépensier je pense le 17
au printemps prochain on est une idée
peut-être un peu plus claire de à quoi
ça va ressemblerisseurs pour pouvoir
réagir à ce moment-là si ça va vraiment
mal mais qu'est-ce qui va arriver avec
les trans ressentez allait rapidement
je pense qu'on va commencer à discuter
que ce sera une longue discussion on va
pas régler ça à la semaine prochaine
puis que ça va être un bras de fer
certainement parmi les plus intéressants
à suivre de l'automne cette saga des
transparence en santé on nous dit que ce
sera possible
parler on verra bien
sa gala Québec solidaire qui a changé
d'idée qui accepte finalement de prêter
serment au roi avant la rentrée
parlementaire du 29 novembre prochain on
va écouter là-dessus Gabriel
expulser le 29 novembre on n'a pas été
élu pour aller défendre notre projet de
société dans les corridors de
l'Assemblée nationale alors on va se
boucher le nez parce qu'on veut déposer
et ce sera notre premier geste
parlementaire un projet de loi pour
enfin rendre ce serment facultatif
autrement dit on va prêter serment une
dernière fois pour que plus jamais des
députés québécois soient obligés de
prêter serment
alors volte-face après la décision du
président de l'Assemblée nationale qui a
dit cette semaine qu'il fallait
absolument prêter serment pour pouvoir
siéger à l'Assemblée nationale Michel
est-ce que Québec Solidaire a pris la
bonne décision dans les circonstances
j'ai l'impression que solidaire est un
peu Tannée d'être à la remorque du PQ
dans ce dossier là depuis le depuis
l'élection finalement
on a parlé que du PQ et ils ont ils ont
embarqué dans un train en marche à
Québec solidaire et là je pense qu'ils
ont pris prétexte du de la sortie de
l'ancien président de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur paradis pour changer
leur stratégie et se dire là vous voyez
on va reprendre la direction du dossier
puisque nous allons présenter un projet
de loi à l'Assemblée nationale
exactement et en toute justice il faut
dire que à la pression précédente c'est
aussi qu'évêque solidaire qui avait
présenté un projet de loi dans ce
sens-là qui a pas pu être adopté mais
qui vont simplement représenter alors et
j'ajouterai que les militantes Québec
solidaire déchiront pas leur chemise
face à une volte-face comme celle-là
tandis que si c'est un monsieur
Saint-Pierre de La Mondor avait décidé
après tout ce qui a dit que finalement
il prêterait serment ça aurait peut-être
moins bien passé au PQ que ça risque de
passer à QS mais c'est une décision qui
a fait réagir le député du Parti
québécois aujourd'hui parce que Bérubé
sur Twitter il a écrit ceci
contrairement à ce qui est Gabriel ado
Dubois affirme dans les médias ce qu'on
appelle Diane n'en n'était pas un de
collaboration mais bien pour nous placer
devant ce fait accompli nous prenons
acte de cette décision nous poursuivons
nos négociations avec la carte sur ce
sujet avec donc le PQ qui accuse Québec
solidaire de cette rallié à la coalition
à venir Québec
n'avait même pas à appeler le Parti
québécois pour leur annoncer la position
d'avance qu'on appelle de courtoisie là
c'est pas une alliance là alors peu
importe qui se sont dit ça pas beaucoup
d'importance là ce qui était le plus
compliqué depuis le début pour cette
dans cette histoire-là c'était que
autant on pqs on allait laisser faire le
travail par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est-à-dire qu'on allait espérer que la
carque ou le Parti libéral allait soit
déposer une motion soit déposer un
projet de loi c'était comme de dire moi
je vais être dans les estrades ici s'il
vous plaît faites le travail pour nous
parce que nous on allait pas prêter
serment c'est ce que Québec solidaire
vient de briser en disant écoutez on va
se passer le nez on va se croiser les
doigts on va le faire comme on le fait
d'habitude puis là on va le faire pour
vrai nous on va prendre l'initiative de
le faire pour vrai je pense que c'est
une bonne décision dans les
circonstances plutôt que d'espérer que
d'autres parlementaires exaucent nos
vœux on va le faire pour la dernière
fois et sans les caméras derrière les
porte-clés
ça a pas d'importance comment ça se fait
il y a quand même une certaine cohérence
là-dedans le changement ça se fait à
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas dans les
esclaves c'est pour se construire à un
moment donné
il y a les pour se permettre dehors
c'est un spectacle qui probablement
aurait beaucoup d'écho dans la bulle
mais pour le reste ça avance personne
mais c'est ça justement j'entends
qu'est-ce que va faire le Parti
québécois dans les circonstances c'est
ce qu'ils vont attendre que la loi soit
adoptée pour pouvoir siéger et ça on le
sait que ça pourrait être long là on
parle pas de quelques jours ou est-ce
qu'ils vont se rendre le 29 novembre
puis risquer de se faire expulser
bon alors à ma connaissance le
particulier a prêté serment à la
monarchie depuis les années 70 et y
compris les deux députés réélu j'ai
l'impression moi que la porte de sortie
qui sont qui vont se trouver c'est que
le chef y repas parce que c'est vraiment
peinture et beaucoup beaucoup là-dessus
dans un coin mais que possiblement les
députés vont y aller parce que c'était
c'était possible de faire ça sans mourir
de honte dans l'Assemblée nationale
précédente est tout à coup ça l'est pas
René l'évêque le fait chaque payso le
fait quand même les prédécesseurs ont
fait mais ça ça voudrait dire quand même
que Paul saint-pierre-flamondon ne
pourrait pas entrer dans dans le salon
bleu à l'Assemblée nationale tant et
aussi longtemps que la loi ne serait pas
adoptée c'est mon impression moi je
pense pas que monsieur
saint-pierre-la-mondon va y aller parce
qu'il voudra pas prêter le serment mais
écoutez j'ai pas de boule de cristal
mais s'il y a le
je pense une musculation abusive de ce
type de clause là qui est tout à fait
légitime la disposition de dérogation et
les crée pour avoir un équilibre entre
le législatif qui est élu par la
population et le juridique qui
évidemment mené par des juges qui se
nomme élu il faut qu'il y a un équilibre
pour un dialogue à un moment donné on
peut pas avoir qu'un gouvernement des
juges jusqu'à la Charte des droits et
libertés allait peut-être créer et donc
les provinces voulaient avoir la
disposition des radiations
particulièrement dans l'Ouest pour s'en
prémunir dans la philosophie je ne pense
pas que quelqu'un s'est dit ça va nous
servir à régler un conflit qui travaille
potentiel qui n'a même pas été déclenché
parce qu'on s'entend pas sur des
salaires un moment donné il faut qu'un
gouvernement ait des syndicats soient
capables de se parler débattre qu'on en
vienne un entente qui est à ce qu'il y a
une loi spéciale ça s'est vu souvent
pour ensuite fixer des conditions de
travail mais utiliser suspendre des
droits de négociation avant même que le
conflit de travail était déclenché on
est dans une autre dimension là et ici
on rapprochait parfois au gouvernement
le gode avec ses fra c'est dispositions
préventives d'aller un peu loin surtout
au Canada anglais imaginez ce qu'on doit
dire quand dogford utilise pour imposer
les conditions de travail à des simples
de travailleurs du milieu de l'éducation
ça va très très loin mais ça fait pas du
tout l'affaire de Justin Trudeau qui
trouve effectivement que c'est exagéré
on va l'écouter justement là-dessus sa
réaction
et ça devient de plus en plus court dans
différents gouvernements puis ça me
préoccupe beaucoup puis on est en train
de regarder les différents outils qu'on
pourrait avoir
du gouvernement fédéral dans ce dossier
là
d'abord ce qu'il faut dire c'est que le
projet de loi de Monsieur Ford qui sera
probablement loi avant que qu'on aille
se coucher ce soir vient de mobiliser
l'entièreté du monde syndical au Canada
pour réclamer des interventions pour
baliser la clause non absence ce qui
aurait des conséquences aussi sur
l'utilisation qu'on a fait au Québec le
gouvernement fédéral jusqu'à présent se
disait quand les causes les
contestations de la loi 21 et autres se
rendront en cours suprême en
interviendra pour parler par exemple de
l'usage préventif la clause nonobstant
mais là la dynamique vient de changer de
deux façons d'abord les pressions sont
beaucoup plus fortes sur Sainte Rudo
pour qu'ils soient davantage proactif et
ensuite il y a les moyens de le faire
sans avoir l'air de s'attaquer au Québec
et je vous dirais moi que la réflexion
sur l'idée que le gouvernement du Canada
fasse un renvoi à la pour poser des
questions sur les balises ou pas de la
clause d'un absent ces discussions là
ont certainement repris à Ottawa
pourrait mener à ce genre d'annonce là
mais là attention on sait pas ce que la
course suprême va répondre mais ça
évoluerait beaucoup plus vite à ce
moment-là étant donné que ça concerne
l'Ontario alors c'est peut-être mais
c'est pas l'Ontario c'est le monde
syndical alors même au Québec je suis
convaincu qu'elle est assez mais la FPQ
ont gardé ça passer et ils savent bien
que François Legault fera pas ça mais
c'est pas le genre de chose que les
centrales syndicales au Canada vont
regarder passer en se disant
il sait pas rien passé cette semaine il
s'est passé quelque chose qui va faire
des petits si le débat public et l'idée
que la population l'opinion publique
ontarienne va se révolter comme ça
attention on parle de garder les écoles
ouvertes plutôt que fermées j'arrive de
Toronto
Ontario mais le syndicat était vraiment
déterminé à sortir quand même dans la
rue demain pour débrayer pour déclencher
ce mouvement de grève illimité
finalement jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve un
arrangement donc vraiment on va suivre
ça de très très près Michel David
Chantal Hébert et Alex Gaston gay merci
d'avoir participé ce soir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI